bonjour et bienvenue sur ma force est
sur le chemin de la tour de maille en
mayenne je sais pas trop quoi dans les
alpes suisses
rexie toupah briques site
c'est à dire que sauf que ça indien que
je trouve assez rigolo même s'il a des
peut avoir des conséquences il va avoir
des conséquences assez spectaculaire
comme vous savez sans doute il y ce
référendum qui a été fait au royaume uni
et le peuple a clairement affirmé son
désir de sortir de l'union européenne
puisque le résultat du référendum g
calcul ap value pour ce référendum et à
l'est de 656 du bas c'est beaucoup mieux
que les 1,5 sigma du vote sur le thème
de la série senso roll et c'est bienvenu
aussi que le critère de la physique des
particules qui est de 5,6 blackarmor
résultat du vote dit que le peuple
britannique veut sortir de l'union
européenne sauf que sauf qui a des
conséquences absolument oui bien cela
déjà il ya un livre sterling qui rechute
lui qui a été en chute libre boullonnois
du référendum
ensuite il ya beaucoup d'entreprises et
des viandes et des universités qui sont
incroyablement part parce que leurs
premiers partenaires sont européens du
coup si la relation avec les européens
se complique c'est tout leur business
qui peut s'effondrer et enfin et enfin
d'un produit politique liant du nord et
l'ecosse ont annoncé vouloir sortir du
royaume uni ont organisé un référendum
qui avait sans doute gagner pour sortir
du royaume uni dans le cas d'un pic site
est là j'aimerais vraiment pas être
politicien britannique parce que là
vraiment et un dilemme horrible d'un
côté ils peuvent faire le break 6 et
oeri et du coup ils risquent des
conséquences économiques et politiques
absolument désastreuse et est en tout
cas qui serait historique
ou alors ils peuvent rester dans l'union
européenne et prendre la décision la
plus anti démocratique de l'histoire
du coup il me semble que la source du
problème c'est vraiment que le peuple
britannique
l'histoire britannique non pour la
majorité pas forcément bien compris tous
les tenants et les aboutissants toutes
les conséquences potentielles d'un bric
site et je reviens du coup à me demander
si la décision d'un vrai site devrait
vraiment être la décision du peuple
et là je vous sens bondir dans votre
chaise et hurler pour - dans votre tête
sinon vive voix mais qu'est ce qu'ils
racontent les est ce que c'est un
connard d'élitiste antidémocratique
alors je vais pas répondre à cette
question quelque peu provocatrice moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est pourquoi des
réactions émotionnelles pour peut-être
dans ce cas pour vous peut-être dans ce
cas pour d'autres de mes auditeurs mais
plus généralement dans beaucoup de
débats il ya un côté émotionnel très
fort qui a paradé qu'on parle de sujets
comme
la démocratie et ça je pense que c'est
par sa cause des connotations qui sont
attachés à ces mots qui sont tellement
tranché qu'elle prenne le pas sur le
sens qu'on pourrait vouloir donner à de
telles expressions oui au fait je suis
maintenant au sommet de la tour de
mayenne voileuse annaba au fond le jura
le gardon j'étais là-bas à la semaine
dernière le lac léman et puis si on tour
un petit peu il ya même le mont blanc
c'est trop cool ce qui me semble que
lorsque l'on parle typiquement du mot
démocratie
la première chose qui saute dans la tête
pour dans l'esprit c'est que c'est un
truc bien alors même que si on essaie
d'y réfléchir de plus près définir ce
qu'est la démocratie c'est loin d'être
évident donc où on sait déjà que c'est
bien avant même de savoir ce que c'est
ce qui est assez bizarre ce qui est pas
du tout souhaitable a priori
sérieusement qu'est ce que la démocratie
est ce que le prix du prochain iphone
devrait être déterminé de manière
démocratique
est-ce que les scripts des vidéos san
son rôle devrait être édité par tous les
citoyens
est ce que le contenu du programme
scolaire devra déterminer par référendum
là je pose des questions qui ont l'air
db le uniquement provocatrice mais au
final elles sont pas si loin de
certaines réalités
quand on sait que par exemple aux états
unis dans certains états il ya des vrais
débats publics où les gens n'importe qui
demande à ce que le créationnisme soit
enseignée à l'école dès le plus jeune
âge dans les écoles de l'américaine
autre exemple de cela c'est à la fin du
dix neuvième siècle la valeur de pi qui
avait été élu dans l'état de l'indiana
par le sénat ce ne me trompe pas et il
était passé à la majorité et puis a
fallu qu'un mathématicien passe et
utilise un argument de certains manière
antidémocratique pour dire que ne peut
pas voter par la loi la valeur de pie et
notamment avec ces nouvelles
technologies qui envahissent déjà notre
quotidien et qui vont continuer à
conquérir notre quotidien avec la
voiture sans conducteur la réalité
augmentée avec pokémon go qui séduit ce
qui va venir encore après un pokémon
uniquement le début et je pas la
génétique tu va complètement changer
tellement de choses qui pourrait
révolutionner la sente le monde de la
santé et l'agriculture même va falloir
légiférer sur tout ça est ce que les
lois la légifération de ces sujets
hautement technique pour hickel vraiment
comprendre tous les enjeux demande
plusieurs thèses sont des réunions de
comité d'experts pour pouvoir avoir une
compréhension ne serait-ce que partielle
de ces questions là est ce que ces lois
là qui vont devoir être passé à au moins
est ce qu'elles devront être élu
démocratiquement
la réponse me semble loin d'être
évidente
le problème avec des mots comme la
démocratie c'est que dès qu'on y pense
on a en tête des phrases qui résonne
avec un accent aigu paris
des phrases qui font écho comme ça dans
notre tête qui se disent à des hommes se
sont pas tués sont même morts pour le
droit sacré à voter et à la démocratie
et du coup on se dit ah mais c'est trop
bien la démocratie et même des gens qui
sont mois pour la démocratie et on se
dit que c'est bien avant même d'en avoir
une compréhension fondamentale de voir
qu est ce qu on entend vraiment par
démocratie ce qui me paraît très très
loin d'être évident plus généralement je
pense le problème avec des termes comme
la démocratie mais pas que et beaucoup
de mots de la langue française c'est que
la commutation est telle qu'elle inhibe
qu'elle empêche toute réflexion saine
alors sujet quoi juste parce que
certains mots de langue française ont
une connotation ultra a tranché il est
impossible d'en peu de biens en parle et
que donc ça c'est quelque chose que je
remarque mais dans tous les débats vous
tous les débats tournent finalement un
jeu de connotations des mots clés et
c'est insupportable parce que ça empêche
d'aller dans des débats dans le coeur
des choses et empêche de parler de vraie
chose intéressante à mon sens et du coup
faire à mesure que je réfléchisse rsa il
ya quelques années on s'est dit qu'il
faut trouver il faut absolument faire
quelque chose par rapport à ça et
trouver une façon de deux d'avoir des
débats sans connotation ça ça n'existe
pas malheureusement
et du coup à ce que j'ai trouvé c'est le
jeu des synonymes à connotation opposé
l'idée de ce jeu est très simple si on
prend un mot super connotée comme le mot
démocratie et on essaie d'en trouver un
synonyme c'est à dire quelque chose qui
veut dire exactement la même chose mais
qui a une connotation opposés alors ce
moment c'est impossible de trouver un
synonyme exacte du coup de trouver un
synonyme approximatif la porte
énormément je trouve à la réflexion et
je vais vous laisser réfléchir un petit
peu cinq secondes à un synonyme et à
connotation opposé du mot démocratie
et pendant ce temps je vais vous faire
un petit 360° parce qu'on a reproché de
pas faire un 360 degrés anr fois quand
j'étais à ittre et a alors fait j'en
avais fait un mais j'ai perdu
l'enregistrement comme une merde voilà 3
500 et 720 degrés à l'est c'est
tellement beau
les alpes vous fait la grosse merde
quand j'étais là au d'autres côté je
n'arrivais pas à me cadrer on voit que
mon t-shirt du coup tout que je refasse
la fin de cette vidéo malheureusement je
la refais pas vous important à pourquoi
il pleut là qu'est ce qui se passe
bref on en est et où heile de synonymes
à connotation opposé de la démocratie
vous en ayez trouvé un alors moi j'ai
rien trouvé un geste pas vous êtes
d'accord je trouve que le mot populisme
est un très bon synonyme à connotation
opposé du mot démocratie
en effet quand on dit que quelqu'un pour
une décision populiste en fait c'est qui
suit l'avis du peuple et ce qui est
amusant c'est qu'on utilise souvent ce
mot de passe on peut y voir hâtives en
disant à effet que ça pour gagner
d'autres voies mais finalement prendre
une décision populiste c'est prendre une
décision démocratique suivre l'avis du
peuple très bon exemple de cela c'est
selon par le jeune éleveur dans cette
superbe vidéo de la swing tonight sur le
prix de l'essence aux états unis
en fait le prix de l'essence aux états
unis n'a pas suivi l'inflation du coût
il est anormalement bas ce qui veut dire
qu'il ya beaucoup moins d'entrées
d'argent pour notamment les
infrastructures liées
août et tout ça qui devrait être payée
par les taxes sur l'essence
l'autre conséquence a bien sûr c'est que
les américains utilisent énormément la
voiture ils seront qu'un intérêt de ne
pas l'utiliser
du coup pour environnements aussi c'est
pas terrible et du coup on va dire
qu'une décision un peu plus éclairés cas
de pas mal de gens qui s'intéressent à
la question de plus près c'est qu'il
faudrait qu'elle monte ce prix de
l'essence
sauf que ça serait ultra
antidémocratique de faire ça d'ailleurs
c'est pour ça que les politiciens n'ont
pas à vous monter le prix naissance
pouvait pas prendre de décisions anti
populiste il voulait être démocratique
là j'espère que vous commencez à vous
dire que si populisme et démocratie en
fait c'est la même chose peut-être
quelle démocratie s'est pas si bien que
ça et plaies qu'il faut pas suivre
aveuglément et défendre aveuglément le
concept de démocratie et c'est vraiment
ça que je trouve intéressant avec ce jeu
des cinémas connotation opposé c'est que
ça permet de se rendre compte que
certains trucs qui ont des fonds façon
acharnée où on défend ça de façon
acharnée uniquement à cause des
connotations et pas franchement à cause
du sens profond des mots pour ce qu'on
cherche à défendre
du coup elle a juste voulu faire c'est
tout vous proposer d'autres exemples de
cinéma connotation de poser pour vous
montrer comment ce que ça peut
révolutionner la même façon dont on
pense à d'autres choses et je vais
utiliser d'autres cinémas prestation de
poser que j'ai des coups que j'ai trouvé
ouais ça vaut ce que ça vaut et
d'endettement en contexte et ça va faire
des phrases outre à perturbante voire
choquantes des phrases que si vous
sortez ça en soirée
n'importe qui le mec va vous regarder
bizarre moi vous dire l'état palois de
dire des trucs comme ça
et en fait le fait de dire n'a pas le
droit de dire des trucs comme ça c'est
une inhibition ça nous empêche à mon
sens de vraiment pousser la réflexion et
on est coincé dans les phrases classique
à dire qui connote notre façon de penser
et qui nous éloigne d'une vision factuel
des choses à mon sens nous par exemple
tout à l'heure vous avez reproché d'être
un élitiste antidémocratique sur
certaines questions une façon d'utiliser
des cinémas connotation opposé pour dire
la même chose que ce que je veux dire là
c'est de dire qu'en fait je préfère
suivre les avis des experts sur des
questions ultra technique dont les
conséquences sont difficiles à anticiper
sans avoir fait d'études au préalable et
que dans ce cas la vie populistes n'ont
aucune raison d'être la bonne décision
d'être une bonne décision pour la
société et il vaut mieux sans doute à ce
moment là suivre les avis des experts et
par exemple sur la valeur de pi bah je
préfère suivre l'avis de mathématiciens
pour le bien de la société au final
plutôt que de prendre une décision plus
populistes et de choisir d'élire
démocratiquement la valeur depuis un
autre exemple lorsque vous allez au
supermarché vous payer plus cher pour
des produits qui sont sauvages et parce
que naturel et sauvage ce sont des
synonymes ses fruits qui viennent de la
nature et que l'homme n'aurait pas
touché et en fait c'est même pas vrai
parce que les produits tout ce que vous
achetez au supermarché
rien de ce que vous achetez
so vanille naturelle puisque tout a été
façonné par l'homme je vous invite à
aller voir ma vidéo sur les éoliennes
pour en savoir plus
autre exemple il ya quelques jours j'ai
se retrouver avec des amis du labo a
parlé de loi récente sur le terrorisme
et
collecte de biome de la bo s'était
plaint du fait que le mot terrorisme
était mal défini et que si on
considérait que le terrorisme c était un
ensemble d'actes prémédités et organisé
par tout un groupe
un but politique et que c'était des
actes illégaux
vincee inclus à son hôte des actions
écolo par exemple de fauchage des
plantations ogm voir la résistance
française est la conclusion de ce de
cela c'est que finalement un synonyme à
connotation opposé du terrorisme c'est
peut-être le militantisme activistes
illégal quoique la sécurisation soient
pas totalement opposé à 80 isme
activistes et légal ça reste comme été
négativement mais bizarrement c'est
beaucoup moins connoté négativement que
le mot terrorisme et moi je trouve ça
intéressant de me dire que en fait
finalement les résistants français
c'était des gens qui étaient organisés
qui met qui pesait d acte prémédité et
organisé qui avait pour but de semer la
terreur dans un au sein d'une population
qui avait pourtant choisi de faire la
paix plutôt que la guerre et tout ça à
des fins politiques en train de 10
milliards ça pour essayer de
contrebalancer la version qui nous est
racontée dans les livres d'histoire à
l'école
tout ça pour avoir une fille née une
vision peut-être plus factuelle de ce
qu'était la résistance française pendant
la suite la gemmi clair il qu'hier c'est
peut-être le mot le plus connoté de la
langue française alors que c'est un peu
comme un hitler a été un dictateur bien
synonyme de dictateurs c'est leader
parce qu au lieu de dire que douteux que
hitler était un dictateur qui mentait à
son peuple on peut voir sa dictée à 2 2
on peut voir est clair comme un leader
qui a inspiré toute une nation et qui
l'a amené à faire un truc que la nation
elle même n'aurait jamais pensé faire si
elles étaient cent
un leader comme hitler tout ça pour dire
que quand une école d'ingé on vous dit
qu'il faut devenir des leaders dans la
vie c'est marrant parce qu'on connaître
un peu note ultra positivement un
concept qui n'a pas forcément de raison
d'être prêt noter aussi positive
non on peut dire que hitler oui il
faisait il est arrivé très bien à faire
ça à bien utiliser une énorme propagande
mais finalement un synonyme de connaître
à connotation d'imploser de propagande
c'est une campagne d'information voire
vulgarisation ce que je fais sur scène
ce soir hall finalement c'est une
propagande pro mathématiques c'est de
vous vendre l'idée selon laquelle la
limmat
c'est bien d'en faire peur alors que
hitler à l'époque son équipe c'est de
promouvoir l'idée que la guerre c'était
bien de la sphère où jusqu'à finalement
la différence entre les deux d'un point
de vue factuel et pas si énorme
enfin on pourrait dire que le caire lui
il a pas investi dans l'éducation en
fait si il ya c'est un de ceux qui a le
plus investi dans l'éducation à travers
ces écoles des zones asie là bien sûr à
l'école on dit que c'est pas des écoles
s'étaient pas de l'éducation c'était du
conditionnement du bois le crâne mais
finalement l'éducation qu'on a reçue ce
n'est ce pas finalement également du
conditionnement et du bourrage de crâne
ne t'ont pas été conditionnés à dire
bonjour merci au revoir
n'ai-je pas été conditionné mois a
constamment poser les questions qui font
mal a toujours remettre en cause tout ce
que l'on m'a dit finalement le
conditionnement notamment à dire bonjour
merci au revoir
ça me pousse à faire des trucs assez
machinalement mais c'était peut-être pas
forcément une mauvaise chose et
al'inverse l'éducation qui apprend à
faire des trucs d'une manière et une
seule manière à finalement c'est du
positionnement c'était pas si bien que
simple enfin un gardien qui en met
préféré
la relation entre intuition et préjugés
quelqu'un qui se basent énormément sur
son intuition
c'est quelqu'un qui a réfléchi
uniquement par rapport à ces préjugés
comme mathématicien qui arrive à prouver
les terrassements édition c'est un
mathématicien qui fait preuve de
beaucoup de préjugés
alors tout ce que je viens de dire c'est
assez perturbant et vous avez sans doute
envie de ne pas du tout adopter tout ce
que je veux dire tout ce que j'ai dit
mais je vous invite à essayer de prendre
le temps vraiment la réflexion c'est les
trucs qui sont vraiment bien faut
vraiment prendre le temps de réfléchir à
tout ça du coup vous invite à ne pas
commenter à chaud essayer de prendre un
ou deux jours à réfléchir à ça et
constamment essayé de spots et les mots
qui sont ultra connoté dans toutes les
discussions que vous avez sur les jt
dans les journaux sur le web et à
essayer de changer la connotation des
mots qui apparaissent dans ce que vous
lisez essaie de traduire en fait ce que
vous lisez en les connotations opposé
pour essayer de voir quel est une vision
que objectifs des choses pâle que celle
qu'on vous offre dans ce que vous lisez
que même façon à ce que vous avez des
débats entre amis ou en famille je sais
que beaucoup de débats d'expérience
finissent par des jeux de connotations
des mots qu'on se dispute sur les mots
et surtout sur la connotation des
boucles et ça souvent ça fait pas du
tout avancer les choses donc au lieu de
rentrer dans sa essayer de mettre les
choses à plat dès le début et d'essayer
de dire bon bah tellement et telmo sont
en fait des synonymes
mais ils ont des complications de poser
et puis surtout essayer d'avoir conçu
d'avoir le débat en utilisant à chaque
fois les mots qui ont la connotation
opposé à ce que vous essayez de dire que
la connotation que vous aimerez utilisé
et si lorsque vous avez utilisé la
commutation opposé ce que vous dites
semble ne plus avoir de sens c'est sans
doute que ce que vous vouliez dire à la
base on n'avait pas trop de sens c'était
juste uniquement un fruit de du piège
des connotations genre médias l inverse
si ce que vous dites a encore un sens
une même après traduction en connotation
vous posez c'est sans doute que vous
avez là quelque chose d'intéressant tout
cas d'expérience je sais que moi ça m'a
fait beaucoup progresser dans ma
compréhension du monde on va dire dans
toutes les réflexions que j'ai 2
de comprendre que d'utiliser ces cinémas
connotation opposé essaie de raisonner à
chaque fois avec la connotation inverse
le celle que j'aimerais utiliser
bon je dis ça mais en fait en pratique
je sois encore en plein dans le piège
des connotations il ya plein de choses
que je dis qu'ils sont uniquement dû aux
connotations que j'associe au mot que
j'utilise et j'aimerais ne plus tomber
dans ce genre de piège dont il faut
encore que je travaille sur ce jeu des
synonymes à connotation opposé
d'ailleurs je n'ai pas de temps que ça
c'est que j ai pas encore assez réfléchi
et je vous invite bobo vraiment à tous
ensemble qu'on s'entraide un petit peu
et que vous m'aidiez en particulier à
mieux comprendre les faits des
connotations sur ce que m'ont dit en
spots en découvrant listant de plus en
plus de synonymes à connotation opposés
dont vous savez je vous invite à les
mettre dans les commentaires et puis
j'ai aussi fait un google chic que je
vous invite à essayer de remplir avec
des synonymes à connotation vous posez
donc là c'est des mains est forcément
sur les cinémas à connotation opposé je
vous invite vraiment à réfléchir à tout
ça à prendre le temps de la réflexion et
à ne pas réagir à chaud parce que h au
bar forcément vous allez dire que c'est
la merde mais je pense qu'avec un peu de
réflexion les choses peuvent évoluer
dans votre réflexion
j'espère que ça va faire évoluer vos
réflexions mais in fine et si vous avez
pris le temps d'y réfléchir à tout ça tu
n'es tout ce que j'ai dit à ses maris
fort sense du coup votre avis compte au
moins autant que le bien donc je vous
invite à le mettre dans les commentaires